James Comey this is the discussion
everywhere it's been fired by trust both
sides are talking we're going to no one
has been consistent here on this and
this is this is what I find most
remarkable about the story I'm sitting
on what's my opinion on this honestly I
don't have much of an opinion other than
I'm really pissed off at the complete
inconsistency of everyone else's
opinions it's been embarrassing for
everyone
McGregor was so embarrassing that Sean
Spicer this was in the news allegedly
hid in the bushes from reporters he was
not ready to deal with this he hid in
the bushes and they have pictures some
say he hid in the bushes they just they
weren't able to find him for a while
although they did catch up with him Sean
Sean D
hey what's the matter what are you
crying for got killed robbed no they're
not no they're not
I promised you the media is not going to
kill Trump now why don't you come out of
there huh would you like some milk we've
insulted you because that is the worst
you know it's just one of those stories
where I feel as though these people in
roles of media and government don't
understand the concept of the Internet
right right now everyone's expressing
their yeah Al Gore does they're
expressing their opinion it's like no
one comes up to me with a long sigh and
you do realize that you as people can
actually just search what you said like
six months ago
you look getting well all I can tell you
is the FBI director has no credibility
director Comey made a great mistake we
we all make mistakes but this is a great
mistake all I can say is that my
confidence and the ability of the FBI
director to lead this agency through the
troubled times that lie here has been
shaken I think it would not be a bad
thing for the American people if he did
stuff top that's embarrassing and now of
course the left they're coming around
saying that Comey was not even Elizabeth
Warren said komen was not fired because
of Hillary Clinton call me was fired
because of the Russians the timing makes
that clear
here's the deal we don't know now could
could call me of been spearheading an
investigation that got pretty close to
tying Donald Trump to Russia I don't
know maybe could Trump just be out of
touch or daft enough that he doesn't
like James Comey and he fired him
regardless and didn't really think about
the horrible timing and how this would
look
yeah but here's the thing the left of
course loved Comey with Clinton running
kind of like okay we're going to move on
and then when he reopened the Clinton
case and spoke led right before election
they hated Comey and then Republicans
they loved they hated Comey then they
loved Comey when this happened as a
matter of fact some would argue that the
reason Donald Trump kept him on board it
didn't fire him day one which I think he
should have done yep because well he
helped me beat Hillary Clinton so
everyone has switched back and forth
three four five times and it's just this
is the issue we've been talking about
this is the issue with if you are
entirely driven by clicks or by viewers
100% by being pro Trump and outright and
Trump and Pepe the Frog and make America
great again or if you're 100 percent
driven by fake anti Trump stories like
BuzzFeed and urinating prostitutes and
CNN when you are entirely beholden to
just being yeah yeah rah rah she's our
Messiah or we hate every single thing he
does you will embarrass yourself you
have made asses of yourself it's too
easy to back check every single one of
you and you had you haven't held the
same position twice in three Court this
fiscal quarter so there that's where I
am so exasperated with this and of
course people they just travel where
your principles getting you right during
the election where your conservative
principles getting your same thing with
left it's all about populism now is just
about getting the vote but about well
really it kept some people from being
embarrassed to high heaven at least that
at least we have some thread of
principles reigning you know keeping
keeping your system together your
life system if you have your drawers
semi-organized
you're not going to get caught with the
wrong socks four days in a row it is
remarkable to me and and what's even
worse is how people aren't embarrassed
by it it's like having the wrong answer
in class but blatantly wrong like you
didn't study for the test but you're not
even embarrassed that your mind
numbingly stupid that's what bothers me
just have some shame in the fact that
you're inconsistent it's like you know
what yeah I'm a really crappy blogger
clickbait who just I was I made my
career off of supporting Trump
and this looks bad or you know us yeah
we built our network off of bashing
Trump this looks bad instead they just
like no this is the way we operate well
what's that whatever would you like at
any given day there's no consistency I
hate it and this is what's wrong with
cable news when no one trusts them hey
if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively talati with better calm
slash mug club members of your student
military or veteran internet promo code
it's less than six dollars a month and
you get daily content no more clips plus
this hand at smug oh I just when I feel
it I got a chill like on the inside